[Music]
intelligence is not a fixed trait
because anyone regardless of age
background or disability can improve
their cognitive capacity
the key for that to happen successfully
is human mediation
[Music]
this idea is based on the theory of
reuven feuerstein a psychologist who was
working with children arriving as
immigrants in israel from north african
communities in the 1950s
to determine their school placement the
children were subjected to a series of
assessments including iq tests
during the assessments feuerstein
noticed that while some children learned
a new task very easily others didn't
under closer examination he realized
that the first group was raised in
environments that favored the
transmission of local culture from
generation to generation
in other words their minds had received
an adequate amount of mediated learning
experience
the second group was deprived of their
original culture and didn't experience
such natural learning
feuerstein then developed his method and
began to distinguish two types of
learning direct and indirect
children who only experience direct
learning may never reach their full
potential kids who also learn indirectly
can
to help the children who are deprived of
indirect learning experiences mediation
comes in the mediator curates the
learning journey selects meaningful
materials sparks the child's curiosity
and provides comfort and feedback
gradually the child then internalizes
this guided experience and becomes
capable of self-mediation that enhances
the direct learning
in other terms mediation strengthens the
cognitive modifiability and as a result
the child will learn more effectively
which is the essence of intelligence
based on these findings feuerstein
developed a dynamic assessment of our
cognitive process and a program of
cognitive intervention
the dynamic assessment focuses on
measuring someone's learning potential
based on the progress they have made as
a result of mediation
[Music]
the cognitive intervention program
provides children and adults with books
tools and materials that enhance their
problem-solving skills
this method is also known as
instrumental enrichment
foyerstein continued to work with
hundreds of children and was able to
document dramatic improvements in the
ability among those who received
intensive mediation of cognitive
strategies
even children who were considered
unteachable eventually made it to
mainstream schools or universities
today tens of thousands have been taught
using reuven feuerstein's methods for
educators he left the following advice
if you are not prepared to look at your
people's strengths don't touch their
weaknesses
what are your thoughts do you agree that
anyone can increase their intelligence
and become a better learner to learn
more about the method visit our website
or reach out to the people from the
feuerstein institute which continues the
work of its founder to this day
sprouts videos are published under the
creative commons license that means our
videos are free and anyone can download
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools governments and
non-profit organizations can also use
them for training online courses or
designing new curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute just visit patreon.com
sprouts even one dollar can make a
difference